bonjour maxime thiébaut merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors on vient
de le voir emmanuel macron a reçu cette
gifle alors qu'il effectue un
déplacement dans la drôme quelle a été
votre première réaction après avoir vu
cette vidéo
l'indignation indignation la plus totale
parce que on s'attaque pas seulement un
homme on s'attaque au président de la
république et le président de la
république c'est la clé de voûte sous la
vème république c'est la clé de voûte de
notre état et s'attaquer au président de
la république c'est le symbole en fait
que notre société et notre république
est bien malade
on est face à une situation qui prouve
que l'ensauvagement n'est pas qu'un
sentiment est qu'il a aussi une réalité
il est une réalité à l'égard des
policiers des gendarmes qui sont
attaqués tous les jours et il a une
réalité à l'égard du président de la
république qui a été giflée donc je suis
je suis vraiment vraiment touché par ce
qui s'est passé en début d'après midi la
préfecture annonce que deux personnes
ont été interpellées que risquer l'homme
qui avait fait à le président de la
république là bas sur le plan pénal il
risque des poursuites assez gras vins et
des circonstances qui qui sont celles de
s'être attaqué à un représentant de
l'état donc on voit qu'il y en a des
dispositifs sur le plan pénal qui sont
en train d'être mises en place notamment
pour protéger tous les maires de la
république qui sont agressés et je veux
des exemples chaque chaque mois d'un
maire qui se fait agresser on a un air
de côte-d'or qui a été agressé hier je
crois que deux semaines et qui a été
dans une situation de santé très grave
aujourd'hui c'est le président de la
république et demain ce sera quoi
on voit que l'ensemble des démocraties
européennes est en proie à la violence
je me rappelle que pendant le bret site
une députée britannique avait été tué et
en france pour le moment où il est
heureusement et j'espère que ça
n'arrivera pas on n'a que des violences
physiques et verbales on n'a pas encore
domicile mais la preuve qu'une
civilisation est en train de s'effondrer
qu'un socle qu'un régime que notre
république
elle assigne en tenez plus solide c'est
celui de voir ses représentants est
notamment président de la république qui
est le représentant sacré dans
l'intégrité physique ne peut pas être
atteinte c'est de voir ces élus de la
république violente et physiquement ou
verbalement et pourtant quelques minutes
auparavant m
mâcon avait appelé au respect et au
calme et ne pas fragiliser la démocratie
en réaction à la polémique suscitée par
les propos de jean-luc mélenchon
cette gifle infligée au président de la
république
qu'est-ce qu'elle illustre selon vous un
recul de la démocratie un recul même de
la civilisation
moi je remarque que la nation française
est en pleine dissimulation c'est à dire
que on a des communautés qui se crée de
toute part on voit des jeunes de 17 ans
qui agressent et qui tuent des gamines
de 14 ans on voit des agressions contre
les policiers les gendarmes tous les
jours on voit que notre état n'est plus
respecté notre état des plus respectés à
la fois parce qu'il incarne et moi je
j'ai reproché très souvent sur votre
antenne l'attitude parfois des manuels
maquereau dans les fonctions de
président de la république où il est
parfois un peu un peu trop proche des
gens sans ceux de ne pas avoir cette
distance républicaine avec eux et on le
voit on le voit tous les jours et on
voit contrario bal des français qui ne
respectent plus les institutions de la
république qui encore aujourd'hui
enfin je ne sais pas qui sont les
individus qui ont fait 7 cette action il
faudrait que l'anc est le déterminer des
terminaux mobiles de leurs actes mais en
tout cas on on est face à une violence
qui est en train de progresser et ne pas
la reconnaître c'est faire preuve de
naïveté
alors avec toutes proportions gardées
évidemment cette gifle
elle n'est pas aussi un symbole d'un
ras-le-bol entre guillemets avec les
phrases choc qu'on a pu entendre à
traverser la rue pour trop versé pour
trouver du boulot pognon de dengue dans
les minima sociaux est la meilleure
façon de se payer un costard c'est de
travailler skis emmanuel macron a heurté
beaucoup de français il a heurté aussi
les politiques qui ont dénoncé des
propos méprisants et violent à leurs
yeux
est-ce que sont selon vous cette gifle
est l'expression violente et
injustifiable d'un rejet du président
sortant qui semble déjà être en campagne
c'est ce que je lui disais on a des élus
de la république et d'internautes plus
les fonctions et les petites phrases
depuis trois ans quatre ans peut-être
prime emmanuel macron ne sont pas à la
hauteur de la fonction présidentielle
alors après de là à dire qu'il ya un
lien direct entre l'agression qu'a subie
le président de la république
aujourd'hui et les propos qu'il a tenus
depuis quatre ans
je ne m'aventurerai pas à le faire et je
me permettrai pas de le faire parce
qu'on ne connaît pas les mobiles de ces
personnes qui agissent mais il est
certain que je pense que le général de
gaulle n'aurait certainement pas subi
une gifle et pourtant et pourtant il a
subi l'attentât du petit clamart
donc il faut il faut juste rappeler une
chose dans l'agression qu'a subie
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'est non pas de chercher la
responsabilité du responsable du
président de la république dans tout
cela mais c'est comment on arrive à
faire renaître notre république à
travers les actes de violences qu'elles
subissent
c'est ça le vrai enjeu le général de
gaulle a réagi à l'attentât du
petit-clamart était un avenir plus grave
parce qu'on a voulu le tuer il faut
qu'elle manuel macron aujourd'hui
parviennent à réagir à la gifle qu'il a
suivi en faisant revivre notre
république
voilà c'est tout la difficulté qui
repose aujourd'hui sur ses épaules
merci beaucoup maxime chievo d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en droit public